clickbait videos it's plagued YouTube
for years but you still click on them
you won't stop clicking and then I have
to click bait just to stay relevant and
gone out of control and I'm here to fix
things so I'm gonna spoil click bait
videos so you won't have to click on
them you're welcome
yes it was painful yes I wanted to kill
myself but here we are let's begin I
shaved my head oh my god Luke shaved his
head that is pubes
yeah I'm joking it's just imagine how
fast it's just a magic effect it's just
a magic effect if internet was real -
there's no boobs in the video if video
games were real 3 0:44 food battle 2010
4:07 worse twist ending ever not 1:46 my
new girlfriend question like hey it's
not easy girlfriend my new hugger it's
not his new girlfriend literally
question mark in title equals not true
don't click on it actually I pulled that
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time ah prankster
got shot who'd prank gone wrong almost
dies no one gets shot the death of
keemstar sadly keemstar doesn't I almost
died today it was makeup PewDiePie is
dead guess what come on was all rank
come on I'm not only dead god damn it's
makeup - oh my god a makeup trick why
did I keep falling for it [ __ ] I didn't
even have a question mark in the title
Teddy rape where's the rape case I what
do you think I clicked on this video ksi
where is it [ __ ] where is it ksi
where the [ __ ] is it that [ __ ] I came
before the title man is PewDiePie Hitler
yes
are we dating Maya says are you guys
dating or what y'all been mad touchy
lately we have been mad at you lately
I think it's just been documented
snapchats just exposing us that was way
to dodge the question ah
are they dating I need to know our
neared answers I guess some questions
will never be answered
I got banged with a toothbrush he [ __ ]
me with a toothbrush why do I feel like
I'm leaving you right now what the [ __ ]
happened bloopers gone wrong gone sexual
where is it you don't need a leaving
will be moving only where is it
yep
see what I mean the problem is an
epidemic look at that dog guys I found
the cream cheese kid ever
just kidding here's to cringe this one
just kidding this is the cringe is one
I'm just [ __ ] with you this is the
craziest one ah no this is the cringes
kid just getting their sister cringe is
king no no no no no no that's the
craziest King guys I'm not playing the
next one will be the cringe is one I
promise the Grinch is kid
the cringy is kid guys leafy I just want
to know what the cringe is kid is why
are you busting my nuts like this come
on man come on tell me who the cringe is
kid is I need to know my friend died
because of me
story time oh what a heartfelt story
better click on this one I know this
seems like a strange story guys but this
really did happen thousands of years ago
this is a story of Easter the real
Easter and the story of Jesus Christ
she's talked she's talking about Jesus
she was talking about her friend Jesus
are you [ __ ] kidding me
I bet Jesus wouldn't clickbait like this
what would you do extreme they're
playing surgeon simulator that all right
why should we name this video guys we
gotta come up with in title how about
surgeon simulator with dad [ __ ] you
we're naming it what would you do
extreme don't believe face client
because I can't believe this happened I
can't believe this you won't believe
this she doesn't believe me I can't
believe these kids can you believe this
I can't believe this I can't believe I
fell I can't believe it I can't believe
I found this I can't believe it
can you believe this I can't believe it
he can probably
oh [ __ ] hell it goes on it goes on
and then finally finally we saved the
best for laughs
good old Keene literally if you see
Peter pie in the title don't don't
bother
alright just Jesus Christ man why do I
feel like he molested me how about you
run that story for a title ah
all right click baiting almost everyone
does it if you don't do it you're not
going to get used I can spend days on a
video and it will get less views than a
video that we [ __ ] out for 10 minutes
that has a better title YouTube is
really unfair and that's regard and what
it leads to is good content sometimes
getting buried by clickable content and
this is a problem that is bigger than
YouTube it goes into news media and
media being biased - I don't mean to get
it that's a whole other level but on
YouTube is it a problem and how do we
solve it we spoil it one video at a time
this has been absolutely [ __ ] awful
for me so I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did go ahead and leave a like
that way I'll get more likes and I'll
have to put less clickbait titles
appreciate you and as always stay
awesome dress this is the Donkey Kong
soundtrack [ __ ] yeah the good Zilla
dance I love this [ __ ] a [ __ ] lip for
the good sir what desk oh yeah my
favorite dance